Bon bah ça y est, on y est les Mentalos.
On a passé les 100 000 abonnés
en moins de 9 mois,
c'est comme si on avait accouché ensemble.
Je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit la meilleure image non plus.
je vais pas vous faire une vidéo de
remerciements larmoyante,
mais avant de vous parler des nouveautés,
des petits trucs exclusives de la chaîne,
je voudrais remercier le YouTube Space Paris
qui m'a ouvert ses portes pour les formations.
Toutes les personnes qui sont passées
dans mes vidéos depuis le début de cette année
et qui m'ont aussi invité dans les leurs.
Et Vous, Vous !
Enfin quand je dis vous,
c'est toi là qui regarde la vidéo, c'est vous tous.
Début janvier sur la chaîne, on était une petite centaine
et si j'avais une vidéo qui faisait les 300 vues,
c'est qu'elle avait buzzé.
c'est qu'elle avait buzzée.. Mais vraiment
en plus c'est à dire que 300 vues ça me rendait hyper heureux
Mais vraiment en plus,
c'est à dire que 300 vues ça me rendait hyper heureux.
Je me disais "C'est cool, y a quand même 300 personnes qui ont regardé la vidéo, c'est formidable."
Et il y avait une ou deux
personnes qui arrivaient chaque jour
et là c'était...  je me disais cette vidéo
était assez cool pour qu'une personne
prenne le temps de s'abonner. Et ça me le
fait toujours peu importe les chiffres, les stats,
c'est toujours une belle
récompense en fait d'avoir un abonné de plus
d'avoir quelqu'un qui regarde une
vidéo. Voilà ça c'est dingue
et en fait c'est parce qu'en fait vous êtes derrière
l'écran t'es derrière ta caméra en train
de regarder la vidéo
c'est pour ça que je suis hyper motivé
à chaque fois. C'est parce que vous avez
partagé, que vous avez liké, que vous avez
commenté que les vidéos elles se sont fait
aussi un petit peu connaître donc je
sais que je le vous le dois
j'ai bafouillé je ne vais pas la refaire parce que c'est ce que je voulais dire
merci encore 100 000 fois!
Maintenant j'ai 5 choses à vous dire
J'ai 5 réponses à des questions que vous me
posez souvent et que je prends bien le
soin d'éviter et aujourd'hui je vais
donner ces 5 réponses là
dont la réponse au fameux engagement que j'avais pris pour les 100 000
Tout d'abord il va y avoir un peu de changement sur la chaîne
Il va y avoir un nouveau logo
une petite intro très courte, de la musique
qui est faite par un créateur, j'en avais
parlé vite fait rapidement de tout ça
une nouvelle fin à la vidéo je voulais
lancer ça pour les 100 000 mais...
Vous êtes arrivés beaucoup trop vite donc c'est
pas encore en place je pense que d'ici
la fin du mois vous allez voir tout ça
arriver sur la chaîne j'espère que ça va vous plaire.
Deuxième chose le Mental meet up quand on était 10 000 abonnés
j'avais pris un engagement qu'aux 50 000 abonnés
je ferai un meet up c'est arrivé tellement
vite qu'à un moment donné la barre des
50 000 on ne l'a pas vu passer
donc je n'étais pas du tout prêt à le mettre en place alors je vous rassure je
suis déjà en train de travailler
dessus et il sera sûrement fin octobre
ou début novembre et pour cette première ce sera à Paris je vous tiens au courant de
tout ça mais en attendant d'ici là si
vous venez me voir en spectacle quelque
part n'hésitez pas à m'attendre à la fin
du spectacle. C'est cool quand on se
rencontre après
vous avez toutes les dates sur le site www.fabienolicard.fr il y a le
lien dans le descriptif, tout le temps, à chaque fois.
La troisième chose c'est que j'ai
toujours fonctionné comme ça par défi
vous savez ça me stimule les deadline
les trucs comme ça, quand on était à 2000
abonnés j'avais lancé un truc pour les
10 000 abonnés. A 10 000 abonnés j'ai
pris l'engagement pour les 50 000 abonnés. Aujourd'hui on est à
100 000 donc nouveau défi mais je
garde la règle de 5. J'ai beaucoup
réfléchi vraiment depuis une semaine
je pense qu'à ça et...
je crois que j'ai trouvé parce que je
voulais faire quelque chose dont
tout le monde puisse bénéficier, toute
la communauté en fait peu importe où
vous êtes dans le monde je vais organiser
une soirée spéciale dans un théâtre
avec plein de choses différentes
pour une soirée que je crois qu'il va
être ouf mais cette soirée elle
sera rediffusée en live directement
sur YouTube gratuitement pour que tout
le monde puisse en profiter en même
temps, en direct. Alors je vous dis
sincèrement je ne sais pas encore
comment je vais le faire. Je ne sais pas
quel contenu il va y avoir, je ne sais pas
avec quel moyen je vais faire ça comment
l'organiser mais c'est pas grave même
si j'ai quand même une idée sur la
contenu. Ça sera drôle,
ça sera mentalisant et ça sera intéractif.
En tout cas d'ici qu'on soit 500 000
sur cette chaîne dans la communauté,
il peut se passer des années, donc je
m'entourerai le moment venu et
on trouvera des solutions à ce moment-là
je crois en ça
voilà vous connaissez le prochain défi
il est à 500 000. Quatrième chose qu'est ce qui se passe l'année
prochaine "-Fabien est ce que t’arrête les vidéos pour 2017?"
non je n'arrête pas, évidemment, après
m'être lancé sur YouTube le 1er janvier
si je réussis à aller au bout
du défi, j'aurais fait 366 vidéos cette
année, une par jour,
sans jamais avoir un jour mort.
Alors je ne compte pas relancer le même défi
parce que ça n'aurait pas de sens et là
ça ne me stimulerait plus pour le coup mais
bien sûr je vais continuer déjà je
vais lancer quelques
concepts différents de ce que je fais
mais avec toujours le mentalisme
en axe principal et je pense qu'il y en a qui
vont vous surprendre de toute manière
j'ai le virus des créateurs maintenant, c'est foutu.
Mais je n'ai pas défini précisément de rythme mais
je crois
qu'au mois de janvier il y aura
beaucoup moins de vidéos que d'habitude
parce que je vais faire une petite
pause je pense qu'après une année
comme ça j'aurais mérité une petite
pause un petit break mais ce ne sera pas sans
vidéo du tout ce sera juste moins de
vidéos et ce break là me permettra
aussi de mettre en place les nouveautés,
les nouvelles vidéos pour 2017 et enfin
la vidéo des 100 000
LA FAMEUSE vidéo des 100 000 abonnés...
Je m'en veux tellement le 1er janvier
donc ça doit être la vidéo n°32
forcément le 1er janvier j'avais fait
une FAQ et vers la 9e minute de la FAQ
je prends l'engagement stupide
de faire une vidéo nu pour les 100 000 abonnés.
Pourquoi j'ai pris cet engagement ?
parce qu'au mois de janvier je crois qu'au
moment de cette FAQ on devait être 700 sur la
chaîne et ça me paraissait impensable
qu'on soit 100 000 avant le 31 décembre donc pour
moi je prenais un engagement à la
légère, c'est un truc qui n'arriverait pas
donc c'était plutôt drôle, on voit le
résultat, ça c'est une bonne
prédiction pour un mentaliste donc je
vais la faire je vais respecter mon
engagement et je vais la sortir, je parle toujours de la vidéo, le 31
décembre et on fêtera la dernière
vidéo de ce défi, de cette année avec la
vidéo je pense la plus spéciale de
l'année et ça me laisse un petit peu
de temps pour aller faire de la muscu
histoire d'être moins ridicule je ne sais pas... je...
Voilà vous savez tout pour ceux qui
suivent vraiment la chaîne depuis le départ
vous savez que  je suis originaire de La Rochelle
à la base et aujourd'hui c'est fou
parce que la communauté de Mentalos
est plus grosse que le nombre
d'habitants de La Rochelle. Pour être
exacte on est plus sur la chaîne qu'il
n'y a d'habitants aux Seychelles mais il fait
beaucoup moins beau... on ne peut pas tout avoir
merci à vous tous et à vous toutes
un par un j'ai vraiment beaucoup de
chance d'avoir une communauté comme vous j'en ai conscience.
Maintenant je vais pas me reposer éternellement
sur l'émotion de ouf que j'ai eu.
Il me reste encore une centaine de vidéos
à faire pour le défi pour cette année
parce que le mental vlog c'est...
vous savez ce que c'est!
MERCI :D